Hi, I'm
Ramona J. Smith. Toastmasters International
2018 World Champion of Public Speaking.
I'm here to share some tips to help you feel
more confident when you deliver a speech.
I know first-hand that speaking in front
of an audience is one of the most demanding
situations you can face. Yet, I'm one
of millions of people who Toastmasters
has helped gain the confidence to
communicate in all circumstances.
We;ll review some time-tested techniques to
help you prepare so that you feel empowered.
When you incorporate these five crucial tips
as you plan and deliver your next speech,
you'll have an easier time, and your
audience will get more out of the experience.
One: Know your subject.
Now, if you want to overcome nervousness,
the first guideline is simply to know what you're
talking about. You'll have an easier time giving a
speech on a subject if you know the subject well.
Want to speak about your favorite musician?
Read verified information about them that
you can find online or at your library.
When you become an authority on your topic, the
audience will want to learn what they can from
you. And, you won't have to struggle to keep your
messages straight if you know the message well.
Once you've mastered your topic, you
need to master your presentation.
Make sure you rehearse the entire speech
so you will be comfortable presenting it,
and practice any difficult parts
repeatedly until they flow smoothly.
Whether or not you memorize each word, you should
make sure you know the order of your messages.
That's why new Toastmasters members
begin with the Icebreaker Speech;
it's a chance to talk about the
subject you know best--yourself!
Then, all you have to focus on is
practicing how well you tell your story.
Two: Know your audience and your space
Understand the importance of knowing who
will be listening to you and where you
will be when you give your presentation.
Both the audience and location can create
limitations that are important to understand.
For example, a researcher might speak
about the math behind their work.
If they're addressing a group of college
professors, they could use highly technical
language to discuss a sophisticated project.
But would they want to do that if they were
describing their work to a group of elementary
students? Of course not! For young kids,
it would be better to talk about how
we learn through the research process.
Knowing your audience means understanding and
respecting their particular characteristics.
Before you prepare your speech, their geography,
politics, culture, age, and other traits will
define them as a group and will guide you in
tailoring your presentation to fit their needs.
Preparation reaches beyond
understanding your audience.
You need to also consider how
they will experience your speech.
For example, when you present to an in-person
audience, be sure to check out your location
before the event begins. Will there be enough
space on stage for everything you need?
If you're planning to use any media that requires
a monitor or a screen, is the venue aware?
Do they have everything you require?
If your presentation will be online or hybrid,
have you learned everything you need
to know about the app you will use?
Can you access chat? Will it be turned off, or
will someone else facilitate that feature for you?
All these questions are important to
answer before you start your presentation.
Three: Keep Going
There s no need to apologize
If you make a minor mistake, such as skipping a
portion of your speech or forgetting a few words.
If something like this happens, don't worry. Your
audience most likely doesn't know the difference.
Just move on and you'll find your way back on
track with your next point. If you apologize,
you call attention to the mistake, which takes
away the important point you want to make.
An advanced speaker knows how to guide
the audience's attention toward the
important parts, and away from the small stuff.
Whether you make a mistake or not, just
remember that people want you to succeed,
and because of that, they're rooting for you.
It helps to remember this with the next tip.
Four: Imagine yourself giving a great speech.
A great way to find success is to visualize it.
Give yourself time for this important form of
preparation. See yourself making clear, valid
points with appropriate gestures and body language
that emotionally connects you with your audience.
Once you see yourself using what works,
you'll feel more relaxed and confident.
And don't forget to imagine pausing
while your audience applauds wildly!
Five: Focus on your message, not on yourself
Some beginning speakers let their nervousness
win because they make the mistake of focusing
entirely on themselves. When something goes
wrong, for example, your reaction can cause
your voice to shake. Then, all you hear is a shaky
voice that becomes the focus of your thoughts.
Remember, you're giving a talk for a reason.
Keep that reason in mind and focus on what's
really important your message.
Find the passion to entertain,
educate, inspire, or motivate your audience,
and you'll find a purpose and your voice.